I know there are some problems I know
they need to make some tweaks to the
robots I understand that because I've
seen them in person first of all they're
gorgeous
this is a bad idea I'm a very jealous
person I do not want to Scarlett
Johansen ass looking robot in my house
I'll tell you this right now if they
make the robots gorgeous there will be a
war
between human women and robot women and
I swear to God we will freaking win
I put Barbie dolls in the microwave till
I was 15 years old
I live to destroy a doll I don't care
about gadgets I don't respect technology
I'll kick Alex in the pussy I don't give
a shit
robot tries to take my man we're gonna
have a problem and I'll be a Savage
about it too I'll wait I'll wait I'll
wait till you fall in love with her then
I'll kill her
I'll just push her in the pool I don't
give a shit
solution for the robot anxiety is so
obvious they just have to involve women
in the designing of the robots that's it
for us to embrace the sex robots they
just have to benefit us in some way like
if a robot is going to have sex with my
man it also just has to be able to like
make guacamole
take an avocado you just put it in her
mouth she's just like
I don't know I'm not a scientist I'm
just saying there's a guacamole mode
we're gonna get through this
I am so confident in my stance on this I
not only argue the sex robots are not
going to replace human women I actually
think they're going to make you guys
appreciate us even more here's why I've
seen them they have hair
fuck do you guys know about doing hair
nothing you're gonna get your robot day
one it's gonna look like Angelina Jolie
two weeks later it's gonna look like
Chucky then what
then what's your big plan huh and you're
gonna call this guy baby will you come
do my robots here
I have to come brush this weird ass hair
and then I'm gonna get emotionally
attached to it because I'm taking care
of it
and I'm not going to have sex with it
anymore
I know I just have a giant guacamole
machine just another Appliance I have to
clean I know exactly how this is gonna
end
it's interesting that even the arguments
I can see myself being the first to make
against the robots I don't buy the big
one I keep hearing is aren't you worried
the sex robots are going to make men
objectify women no that's been happening
for thousands of years I think if
anything we can use the sex robots to
combat the objectification of women what
if we use the sex robots to help teach
young boys consent think about it when
you learn CPR you practice on a doll
first
anyone else think it's kind of weird we
give teenage boys human girls to
practice sex on
I feel like we could start doing is when
a kid turns 15 we give him his own sex
robot he can do whatever he wants with
it four years later he has to turn it
back into a committee who will evaluate
the condition of the doll
that's butthole is it all stretched out
you go back to the beginning
I was a little worried